content creator.
[Music]
Islamic
Islam.
Yeah, she wants she's a student. She's
she's a content creator and she believes
in spending her money and efforts like
you uh in Dawwa. So she's asking uh how
can what what efforts she can do to
become a da
in short
>> sister when you are the content creator
you have to be careful what ladies do
dawa on the social media they can do but
they should not break any rules of the
sharia like sometimes I see ladies doing
dava they come and do makeup and they
record video cassettes this is again the
rule of hijab so you should maintain
your hijab but maintaining hijab doesn't
mean that You can wear a scarf, do
makeup, bell lipstick and come and make
videos and all. My wife is a da
mashallah. She gives lectures. She gives
lectures exclusively to the ladies but
she doesn't agree in taking photo taking
videos. Audio is okay but not video. So
we should see that we do not break the
rules of the Sharia while doing dhava.
There are various ways you can do davas.
You can have program exclusively for the
ladies. No problem.
And you can do on the social media. You
can be good with the pen etc. But see to
it that you don't break the rules of the
hijab. And regarding knowledge of
comparative religion or how to convince
a non-Muslim, you can refer to our
course let's become effective dies on
arida platform. It's absolutely free. It
shows you how to da to the non-Muslim.
Hope that answers your question.